oily skin owners you know how it is
your face is a mirrorball
everything you touch gets oily
makeup slides around
here are my top skin care
and makeup tips for oily skin
it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and shiny person
i live in australia which gets hot
and humid and i'm a youtuber who
has to film in front of very hot lights so
i'm pretty experienced at dealing with oil
here's what i found works
tip one the first thing you want to
check is is your skin actually oily
oily skin is genetic but sometimes the wrong
skincare routine can irritate your skin
and that can make oily or even dry
skin leak out a whole bunch of oil
so it might look like your skin
is oily even if it's not oily
skin can also be dehydrated
which means it's lacking water
even if there's too much oil this leads
to a pretty common dry but oily situation
where your skin feels tight and dry and
cracked but it's also covered in oil
a lot of people who think they have dry skin
actually have dehydrated skin unfortunately my
skin is truly oily technically oily and normal
since my cheeks are more towards normal
and having skin that's prone to becoming
dehydrated combined with a bad skincare
routine made my oily skin even oilier
so the first thing to do if you're
frustrated with too much oil
is to make sure that you're not accidentally
making the whole situation way worse
if you want a really detailed guide to
doing a skin evaluation and a rundown
of the different skin types and conditions
i've done one in my guide to basic skin care
so let's say you've confirmed that your
skin is actually oily what can you do
tip number two wash your face gently it's
very tempting to wash with harsh cleansers
to cut through the oil and try to dry it
out don't do this this is a trap harsh
cleansers will strip away both oil and
your natural moisturizing factor or nmf
this is a collection of chemicals
that are naturally in your skin
they hold onto water and keep your skin hydrated
they're your skin's natural humectant moisturizer
harsh surfactants can also warp
the shape of proteins in your skin
leading to loss of water again dehydrated skin
now your skin has evolved to be
very responsive to its water content
when your skin's dehydrated it's triggered to
produce more oil to keep your skin conditioned
which means more of that whole
mirrorball situation it's a vicious cycle
so gentle cleansing is the way to break out
of this if your skin feels tight and dry after
washing you are probably overdoing it it should
feel soft and plump and if you're used to bone dry
clean skin after washing your face gentle washing
might actually feel like your face isn't clean
it does take some getting used to but gentle
cleansing was the number one thing that helped me
and a lot of other people with oily skin
there are a lot of things that go into finding
a gentle cleanser but the easiest thing to do
is to avoid sodium lauryl sulfate in
the top ingredients of your cleanser
and to avoid soaps i have listed some of
the common ones here their molecules are
quite slim so they insert themselves into your
skin easily staying there and irritating it
and related to this is tip
three try washing your face less
even gentle cleansers can cause a bit of
this dehydration then oil production effect
which is why i think it's worth trying
just cleansing with cleanser once a day
i personally cleanse properly at night
and in the morning i just splash my
face with water and pat it dry with a towel
before doing the rest of my morning routine
skincare products don't just sit on your face
in one big film that blocks
everything else from entering
i think we tend to think of skin like
glass but it is more like a burger bun
stuff sinks in and you can't really
get everything off without also
removing a lot of the bun
or your skin's components
i've found that water in the morning
is enough for me and cutting down my
skin's exposure to cleansers
has helped with the oil a lot
my oil ends up coming back slower throughout
the day instead of just in one big flood
plus the uncomfortable tight feeling and greasy
dehydrated but oily situation has died down a lot
instead of having tight skin with
oil on top which was kind of like
greasy flaky plastic that had
been out in the sun for too long
the oil sort of sinks in a bit more easily and
it's more nice and dewy rather than just greasy
and a lot of people with oily skin
have found that this works for them too
i do sometimes cleanse a second time in the
middle of the day if i've been wearing a mask
or if i want to take off my makeup early when i
do that i use bioderma micellar water which is
super gentle and designed for sensitive skin
it doesn't use proper cleansing surfactants
i've listed a few gentle cleansers
that i like in the description
but remember everyone's skin is different
so it's important to work out what your skin
likes and it's possible that your skin
does prefer to be cleansed twice a day
but i think it's worth experimenting
with this if you haven't already
tip number four sort out your moisturizing
routine it seems to make sense that if
your skin's oily it doesn't need any more
moisturizer since it produces way too much
of its own already but again just like
the cleansing thing this can be a trap
your skin's natural oil isn't actually that
good at moisturizing there are three main ways
of moisturizing your skin there's humectants
which grab onto water and keep it in the skin
occlusives seal the water in
and emollients soften your skin
your natural sebum doesn't do the first
two very well so it just softens your skin
it doesn't actually help with water retention
if your skin is hydrated and oily then you might
not need a moisturizer you have enough of both
water and oil but if your skin is dehydrated and
oily which is the case for a lot of people like me
then having a hydrating moisturizer
that has humectants and occlusives
can keep your skin's water content
up and that helps it control the oil
i like using lightweight products like
toners with lots of humectants during the day
and less occlusives because they can get a
bit greasy and shiny i try to use hydrating
sunscreens i also use a moisturizer at
night sometimes i layer an occlusive
product over humectant for extra hydration
and this has all made a massive difference
tip number five salicylic acid is great for pores
salicylic acid commonly known as beta hydroxy
acid is a chemical exfoliant and antibacterial
skin care ingredient it gets recommended for
oily skin a lot because it dissolves in oil
so in theory it's more likely to be able to
penetrate into blackheads and clogged pores
and exfoliate inside them which
means less breakouts and blackheads
now i haven't seen any actual
studies on whether salicylic acid
is better at this than other exfoliants but it
does sound pretty reasonable i've personally
found that my pores look a lot less noticeable
when i've been consistently using salicylic acid
my favorite is paula's choice 2% bha liquid but
there are lots of different options and if you
want to find out more about exfoliation in general
i have a free guide that i've linked down below
tip 6 is to try some oil reducing skin care
unfortunately there aren't that many skincare
ingredients that have been found to reduce oil
on your face and for the ones where we do have
some evidence there's usually only a single
study so it isn't very reliable and they might
not actually work but if you want to try some
anyway here's the stuff with the most evidence
there's one study where a two percent niacinamide
serum reduced the amount of oil in people's faces
niacinamide is a pretty good option because
it does a lot of other stuff as well
another study found that a plant extract of
sore palmetto in a cream reduced oiliness
some vitamin a derivatives like retinol and
tretinoin might be able to reshape the ducts
that your sebum flows out from and that can mean
it cuts down on the oil pooling on your face clay
is also good at soaking up oil but you do need
to use it regularly to get the benefits because
it is pretty temporary although not super
temporary usually a clay mask twice a week
works pretty well tip number seven is to get
the right translucent powder translucent powder
is one of the most essential products in my
routine for soaking up oil these powders don't
look too obvious on your face so it's really
good if you don't like to wear obvious makeup
and you can just use this over your sunscreen as
well the ingredient that i found works best for me
is starch so i'm always looking for starch high
up in the ingredients list for any translucent
powder i've also tried using cornstarch from the
grocery store which actually works reasonably
well although a proper product is a lot easier
to use there are also some powders that have
clay which tends to be pretty good at soaking up
oil too one thing you can try is commonly called
the wayne goss method where you put a layer of
powder under your foundation so it soaks up the
oil before it gets to the surface and even before
it gets to your foundation so that means it won't
slide around as much i use a big fluffy brush
to try to concentrate the powder on my t-zone
which is the forehead and the nose and also these
bits around my nose which tend to get shiny first
tip number eight is to try dewy makeup it has
been so ingrained into my head over the years that
matte is the way to go with makeup for
oily skin just to beat the mirror ball
into submission but i've actually found
that dewy makeup works a lot better for me
when i do get oily the contrast
between the oily and the non-oily bits
isn't quite as obvious so i look
more healthy rather than patchy
i usually add highlighter on the tops
of my cheeks and the tip of my nose
and a little bit of my forehead as well then i
put starch powder lightly on top and keep topping
up that starch powder as needed throughout
the day and that seems to work pretty well
dewy makeup is also a bit easier to blend back in
with your fingers throughout the day and this is
related to the moisturizing tip try hydrating
your skin underneath before you put makeup on
for example you can try a hydrating toner
hydrating your skin makes it plumper and
less textured it can smooth out
fine lines and reduce flaking
and that means the pigment doesn't have as many
road bumps on your face that can make a bunch up
there are a lot of silicone-based makeup products
and primers that are meant to absorb oil and fill
your pores but i've actually found that these tend
to make me even greasier they're good for about
half an hour until the oil soaks into them and
then i start looking like i'm made of melting wax
it is not a good look but silicones do
work for a lot of oily skinned people
on the topic of makeup tip 9
try using less pigmented makeup
this is not going to be possible or practical
for a lot of people but it is something to try
if you haven't already - using base products
like foundation that have less coverage
basically the less pigment you have on your skin
the less stuff there is that
can move around and bunch up
for example you can try using a sheer
foundation all over and then a heavier
foundation or just concealer on the
bits that need a bit more coverage
i love and i'm currently using trinny london bff
serum de-stress it's a really sheer foundation
that sort of just makes your skin look really
glowy but still natural then after that i use
my fingers to pat in the ordinary's concealer
on the bits that i don't think i covered enough
so in total there's just less pigment
on my face which means the patchiness
and bunched up bits aren't as obvious when it
happens because we know it is going to happen
you can also try using a product
like neon's photography fluid
this has light reflecting particles that
bounce light around and sort of give the
illusion of radiance and smoothness
without actually having skin colored
pigments i found that if i use this before
foundation i don't need as much coverage
and on to my final tip tip number 10
look into medical treatments there
are a few medical treatments
that can reduce oil production
too many androgens which are male sex
hormones can cause excess oil production
so medications that reduce them like some
oral contraceptive pills and spironolactone
can also reduce oil production isotretinoin
which is better known as accutane will also
reduce oil most of the time these aren't really
used for treating oily skin they're used for acne
but reducing oil is part of how they
work if you're interested in these
obviously speak to your doctor and
see if they're suitable for you
there are also some newer treatments that
are promising for reducing oil like botox
and some laser and light treatments
but they're pretty expensive and the
evidence behind their effectiveness
just isn't super convincing yet
let me know in the comments if
there's a tip i didn't cover
if these tips worked for you like
subscribe follow me on tiktok and
instagram more videos are popping up around me
if you want to nerd out more on beauty science